[Musik]
ein freund von mir wurde hier
gestern haben sie ihm abgewandt ich
dachte sie hätten ihn gestern direkt ins
flugzeug gesetzt
aber ich habe gehört dass sie zuerst
noch eine nacht im gefängnis verbracht
hat und er ist heute richtung ghana
abgeflogen ist die letzten springen von
havanna aus ghana werden eilig verwischt
sein zimmer wird dringend gebraucht
es wartet schon der nächste asylbewerber
gestern war ich sehr wütend und traurig
ich fragte mich wieso das leben so ist
man trifft einen netten menschen und
verbringt ein paar monate zusammen dann
verschwindet er plötzlich aber die
schlechten menschen bleiben einem ein
leben lang erhalten
wieso ist das so
was wenn die aussichten trüb sind und es
auch bleiben
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese geschichte spielt im
durchgangszentrum aarwangen im kanton
bern
hier sind 200 menschen aus über 20
nationen vorübergehend untergebracht gut
30 von ihnen müssten die schweiz wieder
verlassen denn ihr asylgesuch wurde
abgelehnt
aber sie können aus verschiedenen
gründen nicht ausgeschafft werden sowie
ibrahim aus marokko marokko nimmt nur
landsleute zurück welche die schweiz
freiwillig verlassen
ich brauche ihm geht jedoch nicht
freiwillig darum kann in die schweiz
nicht auch schaffen
sein freund hat seine aus ghana hatte
weniger glück wäre er nicht freiwillig
gegangen hätte ihm die
zwangsausschaffung bedroht gefesselt auf
einem sogenannten sonderflug
[Musik]
wer glaubhaft versichert die schweiz
freiwillig zu verlassen
die verbringt seine letzten acht zelten
hinter gittern administrativhaft ist
eine zwangsmaßnahme die den weg weisungs
vollzug sicherstellen soll
gefängnisdirektor marcel krise auch die
aus zu schaffen denn hätte es selber in
der hand wie die ausschaffung ablaufe
sprich mit wie viel gewalt
der fachmann spricht von sogenannten
vollzug stufen
wer redet da vor vollzug stufen 1 bis 4
im kanton bern kommt aber vollzug schufa
prüfung gegangen mit so windig der
vollzug schufen eis liegt die
rückzuführen person in einem schacht xii
wort freiwillig mit wird bis auf gold
zum flugplatz begleitet von polizisten
oder politik stehe im fokus hieß es
tickets über die nötige papiere und
werden auch eine vielzahl stand die das
herkunftsland wo sie eher hoch sind
der vollzug stufe 2 person nicht willens
ist reisen sie durch das verweigern und
entwicklung wird sich ob politisch oder
polizistin wird auf den flugplatz
begleitet und im flugbegleiter bis zum
herkunftsland und tätern im prinzip
übergeht der odette sind vollzug stufe 4
das garten richtig dewag war person von
vornherein kundtut dass sie sich für die
wehr physischer wäre und er wird sie
holt mich immer der betrieb auch vorher
einsatzbefehl über mir dann wüsstet und
wähler zeitpunkt was polizei danach und
das ist sind polizisten vom op de und
die person wird noch einer da abgeholt
mit dem transportfahrzeug lothar of the
board of them
im fokus wird sind auch eine botschaft
zusammen mit anderen wo ich dann so
unser flug nach eine gesammelt werden
solche sonderflüge seien aber nur bei
fünf prozent der ausschaffungen nötig
sagt lee in 90 prozent der fälle reiche
vollzug stufe 1
biel endlauf stammt aus mazedonien sein
asylgesuch wurde ebenfalls abgelehnt
trotzdem kann er nicht ausgeschafft
werden denn er hat krebs
haben sie eine freundin ja ja ich habe
keine freundin haben meine kinder ihre
kinder ja die immer kontakt mit der
kinder pro wochen vielleicht drei vier
mal die fragen wie geht bei und etwas
rennen und das ist für mich besser kommt
mit dem hoffnung hoffnung auf nokia für
meine jährige am bbi sagen ich wollte
zwar geheim eine rührige nicht so abend
stress sonst manchmal ich ansprechen
werden meine kinder habe ich schon lange
zeit nicht in 13 jahre um diese 30 jahre
immer möglich während ihre kinder 19 88
aus sich die lage auf dem balkan
zusehends verschlechterte flüchtete
darauf nach deutschland 2003 aus der
balkan krieg längst vorbei war wurde er
nach mazedonien abgeschoben
seine kinder durften in dessen
deutschland leiden oder 2010 zu ihnen
zurück wollte modell in der schweiz
aufgegriffen
jetzt sitzt erinnerungen fest
wenn sich alle jung kommt aus china
weil er seine papiere verschwinden ließ
und sich weigert sich gegenüber seiner
botschaft zu identifizieren stellt in
china kein ersatz reisedokumente aus und
ohne reisedokument kann er nicht
ausreisen
ich liebe arbeit gehen dann keine
papiere keine ausweis keine arbeit
ich denke hier keine einmal probleme
machen keine politik keine diese strafe
in der schweiz lebe herr li versucht das
durchgangszentrum sauber zu halten indem
er putzt und wäscht
gleichzeitig kann man sich so etwas dazu
verdienen also abgewiesener asylbewerber
lebt er von nothilfe also von 8 franken
pro tag
weil er freiwillig arbeitet kommen jede
woche 30 franken in form von
essensgutscheinen dazu
auch ibrahim aus marokko bessert sich
sein nothilfe geld durch freiwillige
arbeit auf als ein freund haus sonne aus
ghana aus geschafft wurde
streicht er die zimmer der abgereisten
neuerdings allein wenn du keine papiere
hast findest du keine normale arbeit
dann kannst du nur hier drin arbeiten
und verdienst ein paar franken
damit kannst du deine familie nicht
helfen ich war einmal dabei als hasan
mit seiner tochter telefoniert hat sie
sagte du bist doch jetzt in der schweiz
und die schweiz ist doch ein sehr
reiches land wie so findest du dort
keine arbeit wieso schickst du uns kein
geld
sie konnte nicht glauben dass er hier
ohne papiere nichts verdienen konnte
[Musik]
und dann scheint die liebe trotz allem
über die trostlosigkeit triumphiere zu
wollen
jedenfalls zeigt eine emigrieren seit
kurzem bemerkenswert großes interesse am
streichen von zimmern
wir sind nur freunde
ich denke sie ist ein wenig verliebt in
sie ich weiß es nicht aber wir wissen
alle dass ich mit jedem nett bin und
allen helfern
ich mache mit allen frauen spaß und sie
hat mir einmal erzählt dass sie einen
freund
sie sind mehr interessierten schweizer
frauen oder ich habe noch nie mit einer
schweizerin gesprochen
ich bin ein bisschen schüchtern außerdem
kann ich kein deutsch
wenn er eine schweizerin heiraten könnte
wären all seine probleme gelöst
ibrahim könnte in der schweiz bleiben
ganz legal
ich bin ein sehr armer mann ich habe
nichts ich glaube nicht dass ich eine
frau finden die mich will wenn ich kein
geld habe das sehr schwierig
jaja von unterwegs zum einzigen
höhepunkt der woche immer am
donnerstagmorgen wir die nothilfe
ausbezahlt auch franken pro tag das
macht 56 franken pro woche
da auch nothilfebezüger ein dach über
dem kopf brauchen und medizinisch
versorgt werden müssen kosten sie den
steuerzahler mehr im durchschnitt rund
450 franken pro monat und person
die anzahl der nothilfebezüger kommt und
bayern schwankte in den vergangenen
jahren stark
es waren zwischen 1000 und 2000 personen
die jährliche gesamtkosten zwischen fünf
und zehn millionen franken verursachten
die bereitschaft der schweiz echte
flüchtlinge aus an leib und leben
bedrohte aufzunehmen ist unbestritten
dass ibrahim sogenannte
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge haben indes einen
schweren stand
sind sie ein richtiger aber marokko ist
ein sicheres land
marokko ist ein sicheres land
aber meine situation ist speziell ich
bin bei pflegeeltern aufgewachsen
diesen juden aber darüber möchte ich
eigentlich lieber nicht reden
wenn die leute wissen dass meine eltern
juden sind werde ich nicht mehr
akzeptiert sie verstehe nicht wie man
mit guten zusammenleben kann
aber sie sind muslime früher war ich
nicht muslimen früher hatte ich keine
religion
dann habe ich irgendwann entschieden
dass ich jetzt muslim aber ich bin nicht
streng gläubig ich bin einfach
ob diese geschichte stimmt oder nicht
ist egal ich brauche ihm kann sowieso
nicht ausgeschafft werden weil in
marokko nur zurücknehmen wenn er
freiwillig ging aber er geht eben nicht
freiwillig für den migrationsdienst des
kantons bern und der eines von vielen so
genannten vollzugsprobleme claudia
ransberger leitet im bereich asyl und
rückkehr und stellt fest die zahl der
aus geschafften ist regelmäßig nur etwa
halb so groß wie die zahl derer die
gehen müssten
es gibt es jene grün für die differenz
sind einerseits sicher personen wonach
im negativen entscheid sich selber in
wahrheit also unter kaufen als die
personen wo es mögliche rechtsmittel den
die reichen und dort dadurch einen von
zug stoppt erreichen
es gibt aber auch schwierigkeiten im
wahlkreis vollzug das heißt dem papier
beschäftigt oder die organisation vor
der rückreise gibt es spezielle lampen
muss ich sofort zu schwierigkeiten
feststellen es gibt diverse länder wurde
vollzogen sehr einfach zu organisieren
ist es ist unter anderem algerien
marokko eritrea äthiopien afghanistan
also wenn die nicht wirklich wandlungs
reise dann haben sie einen dazu bewegen
sich aktuell zum beispiel für marco ist
es richtig wenn person nicht
selbstständig wirklich wird bei mir als
behörde kein vollzug zweite
[Musik]
die brauchen bleibt also zumindest
solange wie die zusammenarbeit der
schweiz mit marokko nicht richtig
funktioniert sollte sich dies jedoch
ändern
ist er bereit bis zum äußersten zu gehen
ich wäre zu allem wenn ich zurück müsste
würde ich mich umdrehte oder mir ein
bein brechen
ich würde alles tun damit ich nicht
ausgeschafft wird ja oft wollte vor drei
jahren freiwillig gehen allerdings nicht
nach mazedonien sondern zum lieben gott
ja habe ich schon eine schere genommen
funk her einfach diese schere genommen
und dann hier geschnitten die kabel so
geschnitten und angenommen
ab hier gemacht denn die fans drauf
gemahnt fenster und der festgenommene
gemacht fest
und dann habe ich die sprint hinter war
eine minute ich weiß dass ich habe mich
abgegangen
nachher abgegangen und manchmal runter
ich kenne nicht mehr was passiert mit
näher und so sie wollten sich umbringen
ja genau
die rega brachte ihn nicht zum lieben
gott sondern ins inselspital
eli und seine frau haben eine
mittlerweile zehnjährige tochter die in
aarwangen zur schule geht eine
aufenthaltsregelung für die ließ wäre
laut migrationsdienstes kann uns bayern
nur im falle einer schwerwiegenden
persönlichen herr tvs möglich und wann
so einer vorliegt ist ansichtssache
[Musik]
[Applaus]
manchmal zieht es ja auch dorthin wo
sich die tür zur welt einen spaltbreit
zu öffnen verspricht zum gratis weichei
verbindungspunkt des durchgangs zentrums
ab und zu versucht er seine tochter in
deutschland zu erreichen
ab und zu macht er sich auf die suche
nach momenten der nähe aus der ferne
und noch ein bisschen heiterkeit in
einer ausweglosen situation jetzt hast
du schnell sind aber menschen machen
vergessen wie schnell ich wünsche ich
schon sagt sabine schnadt und morgen
[Musik]
ok
hatten sie nach zweifel ob es gott wir
richten
ich kenne viele leute die nicht glauben
dass es gott gibt
ich sehe es anders wollen sie wissen wie
sie wenn sie schmerzen haben dann ist
dieser schmerz real für sie aber sie
können diesen schmerz niemandem zeigen
trotzdem fühlen sie den schmerz so ist
es auch mit gott
man kann ihn einfach spüren und ist er
ein guter gott
[Musik]
sie brauchen ich danke dir was vom kreuz
für meine sünden gestorben bist ich
hoffe dir zu meinen leben und nimmt ich
aus meinen retter und keren ann mitte
regieren meines lebens und hält sie so
zu leben wie du geburten kamen
danke für diese aufmerksamkeit und
schöne ende noch
[Musik]